schon genommen herr bundeskanzler und
intensives danke dass sie bei uns sind
damit ist klar wo sie jetzt im moment
sind tatsache bleibt allerdings dass
viele nicht nur auf twitter sie in den
letzten wochen doch ein bisschen
vermisst haben das ist ja vielleicht
auch ein ganz schönes gefühl für sie
aber es gibt natürlich herr gewaltige
herausforderungen deswegen fange ich
vielleicht mal ganz konkret an mit einer
frage der französische präsident hat
gerade zweimal mit wladimir putin
telefoniert
der italienischer kollege auch der
britische heute wann haben sie das
letzte mal mit putin besprochen
beschäftigung intensiv mit unseren
verbündeten partnern in der europäischen
union mit der frage der ukraine kaum
eine sache beschäftigt uns mehr und
natürlich habe ich auch mit dem
russischen präsidenten gesprochen und
wir bereiten natürlich sorgfältig alters
vor was jetzt notwendig ist ich werde
jetzt in die usa fahren ich würde auch
in kürze in moskau weiter sprechen über
die fragen die dann notwendig sind und
es geht schon darum dass hier
koordinierte politik stattfindet dass
die europäische union und die nato
betrifft aber es geht auch darum dass
wir gut vorbereitete entscheidungen
möglich machen und das geht eben nur mit
harter arbeit in kürze in moskau haben
sie gerade gesagt das heißt es gibt
einen gesprächstermin mit wladimir putin
und olaf scholz im kreml das ist geplant
und wird auch bald stattfinden wie sie
wissen geben wir das immer rechtzeitig
vorher bekannt wann das genau sein wird
so wie jetzt auch die reise in die
vereinigten staaten von amerika die ja
auch zu einer ganz sorgfältigen
kooperation gehört mit dem
amerikanischen präsidenten und vielen
gesprächen die wir geführt verschiedenen
gelegenheiten
der bundeskanzler die große frage die
gerade alle umtreibt glauben sie dass es
einen neuen krieg in europa geben wird
glauben sie dass wladimir putin in die
ukraine einmarschieren wird die lage ist
sehr ernst und man kann auch nicht
übersehen dass der sehr viele soldaten
und truppen an der ukrainischen grenze
aufmarschiert sind das ist alles das was
die voraussetzung für eine solche
militärische aktion sein könnte und
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir sehr
klar sind in dem was wir sagen und in
dem das wir vorbereiten nämlich dass es
einen sehr hohen preis haben würde die
territoriale souveränität
und integrität der ukraine zu gefährden
dort militärisch anzugreifen und ich
glaube diese botschaft ist auch
verstanden werden und gleichzeitig haben
wir alles dafür getan dass all die
aktivitäten unternommen werden die für
gespräche notwendig sind damit es genau
zu dieser situation nicht kommt es gibt
die gespräche die der amerikanische
präsident auf den weg gebracht hat
bilateral zwischen russland und den usa
es gibt die gespräche zwischen der nato
und russland im nato-russland-rat es
gibt die gespräche im rahmen der osze
und natürlich das sogenannte normandie
format und deutschland frankreich
zusammen mit der ukraine und russland
versuchen aus der jetzigen sehr
verfahrenen situation herauszukommen und
das haben wir auch tatsächlich wieder
mit leben füllen können ist hat viele
gespräche gegeben in diesem raum es hat
nur noch keinen durchbruch gegeben und
auch noch kein richtiges wissen was
wladimir putin da tatsächlich plant der
westen sie haben es gesagt reagiert mit
einer mischung aus verhandlungsangebot
und drohen mit sanktionen
was ist denn das für ein gefühl wenn
verbündete also die verbündeten
deutschlands jetzt die haltung
deutschlands als unzuverlässig einstufen
das geschieht nicht alle wissen ganz
genau dass russell muss ich ja konnte
unterbrechen ihre eigene botschafterin
in washington die hat nach berlin
telegrafierte berlin wir haben da ein
problem
in den usa sagen die leute jetzt
deutschland sei unzuverlässig und zwar
im kongress aber auch in der
administration
unsere verbündeten wissen ganz genau was
sie uns haben sind diejenigen die einen
ganz hohen militärischen beitrag im
rahmen unseres verteidigungsbündnisses
der nato leisten das weiß jeder ganz
genau für kontinentaleuropa ist
deutschland das land das sehr sehr hohe
aufwendungen in diesem zusammenhang
treibt und selbstverständlich weiß auch
jeder genau was das bedeutet dass
deutschland das land ist es die größte
hilfe für die ukraine in den letzten
jahren auf den weg gebracht hat fast
zwei milliarden euro sind da mobilisiert
worden um die wirtschaftliche
unabhängigkeit der ukraine zu
stabilisieren und ihr zu helfen dass sie
auf eigenen füßen stehen kann gute
entwicklung nehmen kann alles das ist ja
teil der dinge die da bewertet werden
und im übrigen gilt hier sind eng
miteinander abgesprochen wir haben gute
vorbereitung für die schwierigen
situation aber auch eine gute
vorbereitung für das was wir jetzt alle
versuchen nämlich einen weg zu finden
wie man aus dieser situation
herauskommen überall die gesprächs
formate die ich eben berichtete aber das
kannst du sie wieder mitbekommen haben
welche zweifel ist da gibt in
verschiedenen staaten ich bin jetzt kein
politiker aber ich würde mal denken dass
man sowas doch vielleicht durch einen
kraftvollen auftritt eines
bundeskanzlers aus der welt schaffen
könnte haben sie das nicht gemacht weil
ihre eigene partei die spd uneins ist
über den richtigen russland kurs der spd
ist ja einig und sie steht hinter der
politik der kanzler verfolgt und die ist
sehr klar übrigens schon seit sehr
langer zeit und immer wieder sehr
präzise beschrieben wir haben klar
gemacht und klargestellt ich ganz
unmittelbar dass eine verletzung der
territorialen integrität der ukraine
nicht akzeptiert würde und hohe preise
hätte für diejenigen die das machen für
russland gleichzeitig aber auch alles
dafür getan dass jetzt ein weg gesucht
wird wie wir über gespräche eine
friedliche entwicklung in europa möglich
machen können wissen sie viele
bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes
fürchten sich davor dass es tatsächlich
zu der situation kommen könnte nach der
sie mich gefragt haben nämlich einen
krieg in europa das ist unsere
gemeinsame aufgabe mit dieser
doppelstrategie dafür zu sorgen dass es
eben dazu nicht kommen bei jeder aufgabe
bei jeder herausforderung haben ja auch
immer von den erfahrungen der vorgänger
lernen wie sehr hören sie aktuell auf
den rat von gerhard schröder
ich bin nicht um rat gefragt er hat mir
auch keinen gegeben aber er hat
öffentlich rat gegeben und der ist
komplett konträr zu allen fakten und zu
dem was sie hier sagen und in der welt
kommen jetzt zwei bundeskanzler von der
spd quasi an ein ehemaliger und ein
aktueller mit komplett unterschiedlichen
messages bin ich die verfassungsordnung
der bundesrepublik deutschland richtig
verstehe gibt es nur einen bundeskanzler
und das bin ich
zum thema linie klar machen herr
bundeskanzler präsenz zeigen sie haben
gestern sicherlich mitverfolgt wie
dänemark praktisch alle corona
beschränkungen aufgehoben hat obwohl es
dort in dänemark viermal mehr
infektionen gibt als bei uns hier in
deutschland im moment ihre kolleginnen
in kopenhagen die geht ein kalkuliertes
risiko ein und die sagt jetzt willkommen
im leben das wir vor der pandemie hatten
ich nehme an das ist ein satz den würden
sie denn würde wahrscheinlich jeder
politiker sehr gerne auch sagen warum
tun sie es nicht die lage ist nicht
danach wir haben in deutschland ja einen
sehr klaren kurs verfolgt der uns auch
geholfen hat wenn sie die
infektionszahlen anschauen dann sehen
sie die sind hoch aber sie sind nicht so
hoch wie bei den nachbarländern weil wir
rechtzeitig sehr weitreichende
beschlüsse gefasst haben auch über
einschränkungen bei kontakten zumutbare
ist es ja nicht zu einem lock down
gekommen aber mit regeln über zwei g2 g
+ 3g im öffentlichen verkehr mit kontakt
beschränkungen auch im privaten bereich
und bei großen veranstaltungen und das
hat dazu geführt dass die
infektionszahlen bei uns erst sehr viel
später hoch gegangen sind dass wir
deshalb auch besser durch diese lage
kommen trotz all der tatsachen die wir
da zu beachten haben als viele unserer
nachbarländer und ich halte diesen weg
auch für richtig aber in der oberklasse
infektionszahlen viermal so hoch wie bei
uns und die machen jetzt trotzdem alles
auf hat die dänische regierung einfach
mehr mut als die deutsche ich glaube wir
machen das was für die bürgerinnen und
bürger in diesem lande richtig ist
nämlich dafür zu sorgen dass wir
möglichst viele leben und möglichst viel
gesundheit schützen durch diese
maßnahmen die wir auf den weg gebracht
haben einvernehmlich mit den ländern mit
beschlüssen im deutschen bundestag als
grundlage dafür
und auch von einem sehr großen konsens
in deutschland getragen jetzt muss man
alles zeigen es dass die voraussetzung
dafür dass wir auch wenn wir den
höhepunkt der infektion hinter uns haben
werden dann über lockerungsschritte
entscheiden und beraten können aber da
sind wir leider noch nicht angekommen
und dass wir auch noch erreichen müssen
ist dass möglichst viele sich jetzt eine
auffrischungsimpfung holen da sind wir
sehr hoch gekommen viel höher als in den
meisten nachbarländern aber da geht noch
was und dass wir auch gut damit wir
weiter sagen können schaffen es trotz
der bedrohlichen situation dass die zahl
der toten und derjenigen die schwere
gesundheitliche
gefahren erleben müssen kleiner ist als
sonst und das ist ja diese mühe wert
herr bundeskanzler mit blick auf die uhr
und entlang unserer linie klarer kurs
und präsenz zeigen da müssen noch ganz
kurz zum thema olympia reden auch da ist
es schwer eine klare linie zu erkennen
ob sie hinfahren nach peking ist die
frage die deutsche presse agentur
schreibt heute scholz legt sich nicht
fest die spiele beginnen in zwei tagen
ihr habt keine reisepläne also sie
werden olympia nicht besuchen ich habe
keine reisepläne deshalb kann man nicht
davon ausgehen dass sich plötzlich der
auf teure sache hallo hier bin ich okay
sagt der bundeskanzler olaf scholz im
zdf heute journal ich danke ihnen für
das gespräch